- So, wait, you were in
Meghan Trainor's last,
"Made You Look," the hit.
- Oh yes.
- Yes.
- Yes. Yeah.
(audience applauds)
- I saw that and I was like,
"Wait, I didn't know
y'all knew each other."
I had no idea.
- Yeah, it was-
- How did that happen?
- [Scott Hoying] It's
a crazy story actually.
We were acquaintances and we
texted sometimes and stuff,
and when we got engaged
actually, Mark and I,
she texted me, "Congratulations."
- [Kelly] That's nice.
- And I was like, "Thank you so much.
What have you been up to?
I haven't talked to you in forever."
And she's like, "I'm working on music.
Do you wanna hear anything?"
And I was like, "Yes, send everything."
She sent a couple songs.
"Made You Look" and "Bad For Me."
- Yeah.
- I was like, "Made You Look is a smash".
I was blown away.
She's amazing.
- Yeah.
- And then "Bad For
Me", I've been producing
and writing a lot
and so I, for fun, just put a choir on it
and I was like, "If you want
a choir version, here you go."
- I love that.
- And she loved it.
She's like, "I'm gonna
use this for the album
and also come over tomorrow"
and so (laughs) we started
working together a lot
and she's amazing.
- I love how organic that is.
People didn't put people together.
It happened to happen.
That's cool.
- Yeah.
She's so hands-on with
the music she makes.
It's really amazing.
- Yeah.
- And I just really
respect that.
- And you were right,
it is a big hit.
"Made You Look".
- It is a smash.
- Yeah, you were right.
I'm gonna send you
all my music.
(Scott laughs)
If you're the guy that knows (laughs).
- (laughs) No, I'm not
the guy that knows at all.
It was just so obviously a smash (laughs).